Judy Barford example Lamesa hub is a
striking and gritty portrayal of police
violence social exclusion and childhood
the oscar-nominated French film is set
in the Paris suburb of morph ma it
reveals the hardship of people's lives
but steers clear of cliches as it
follows three low paid police officers
battling to keep the peace but with a
heavy-handed approach that makes things
worse
many of the film's actors a residents
from a housing estate non professionals
including activist al nami kanuti who
plays an enigmatic owner of a fast food
restaurant to whom police and young
people turn to for advice for decades
we've seen a denial of police violence
recently we saw the repression faced by
the yellow vests protesters where many
people discovered police violence but we
have always known about it because
today's repression was refined for years
in the suburbs portraying life in the
suburbs came naturally to director latch
Li who grew up in Marfa Mae and began
filming police violence as a pastime he
says that for decades French governments
have ignored the suburbs where
unemployment high and Opportunity scarce
he hopes the film will act as a wake-up
call nothing's changing schools in the
suburbs are a catastrophe cultural
associations had their subsidies cut so
this film is a cry for help to say
listen to us because it's more than 20
years that it's been going badly and we
feel like no one hears us lemmie Sahab
is bleak but its success has delighted
residents in more thermae at the local
football club few imagined that a story
set in their neighborhood would be
nominated for an Oscar the fact that the
director largely comes from more film a
is obviously a huge source of pride here
and it is particularly exciting for
these teenagers because the filmmakers
and the Football Club are flying some of
them to Los Angeles for the occasion
Oscar we started despite the reality
there are so many talented people in the
suburbs
sadly proves that even young people in
the suburbs can make it at the airport
that countdown to Hollywood begins the
trips a unique opportunity to explore
new horizons represent France and cheer
on largely a local hero who's inspired
them to believe in their dreams and
prove that it doesn't matter where you
come from it's where you're going that
counts
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Paris